welcome to the Scorch the world outside
hanging on by a very thin thread beyond
this door lies the beginning of your new
lives I am Mike Zimmer from FX guide.com
for Wired where the digital has just
completed work on the Scorch Trials the
new Maze Runner sequel for director Wes
ball now this film has about twice the
budget of the earlier film but initial
box office indicates that money was very
well spent in the sequel Wes ball has a
much broader and bigger canvas to paint
on in the first film the story kind of
meant that we would never actually see
everything well not until the end but in
this film
our hero see virtually nothing but vast
horizons and huge empty cities typically
environment work or set extensions are
built with almost like kit componentry
that's then textured what's fascinating
about this film is how wet are built and
textured this mythical post-apocalyptic
city now we only ever see the city
destroyed but to get the accurate ruins
we're to built normal buildings and then
ran a series of destruction simulations
on them so we have not just some 3d
model rubble or some bent reinforcing
but sort of plausibly accurate
destruction the debris in these shots
actually fell there wasn't just placed
by an artist this is really unusual
normally visual effects companies are
paid to make and film the destruction of
cities not to destroy everything
beforehand accurately and then just to
only show us that desolate results
afterwards not only were the buildings
all accurately modeled but there were no
matte paintings not even for the distant
ruins at the insistence of veteran VFX
supervisor Richard Hollander but where
does team took an even a step further
than that all the buildings are unique
they're not just copied and pasted
they're all there in the same
environment or correctly reflecting
light and shadowing each other as they
would
thanks to wetters new Manuka renderer
chris white who headed wetters team told
us not only did the entire world get
built and rendered as one but even the
texturing was done primarily by
simulations and not by hand painting all
the kind of water and rust textures at
UC and not hand-drawn
Chris's team actually ran water
simulations thought that you'll actually
get to see them of course and all the
kind of flapping cloth and plastic you
guess that they encased each building in
some kind of giant sort of sock cloth
simulation and then the cloth court on
only those parts of the building that
cloth would catch on in fact for all the
deserts we actually see in this film
director Wes ball only ever had three
actual sand dunes the film on the rest
are all sand simulations even the patina
of the worn concrete was weathered with
particle simulations basically if this
city ever got built and then deserted
this is a vastly accurate simulation of
what it would actually look like the
environment work been extended to inside
the building where the underground
sewers are home to the zombie like
cranks although the lesser infected
souls above-ground were basically done
with physical makeup by a DI the really
evil cranks below were fully CGI motion
captured with double-jointed circus
actors providing the motion they were
then modeled with a cross between some
kind of vine like vegetation and a
horrendous real disease that Chris white
found online called subcutaneous horn
and trust me do not Google images of
that in the end of course most of our
gliders survived but there is always
that third film that Wes ball is about
to go into pre-production of as we speak
well please subscribe for more behind
the scenes action I'm Mike Seymour for
wide